hey everyone welcome to this video
tutorial by simply learn
in this video we'll learn an interesting
topic that is how to become a business
analyst
but before i begin please make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell icon to stay updated
with all the latest videos on our
channel
first let's understand who exactly a
business analyst is
business analyst is a professional who
is responsible for bridging the gap
between it
and business teams they use
analytics to evaluate processes
determine requirements deliver
data-driven solutions
and generate reports to executives and
stakeholders
business analyst is an individual who is
a part of the business operation
and works closely with the technology
team to improve the quality of the
services being delivered
they also help in assisting in
integration and testing of new solutions
growing a career in a field with high
demand such as business analysis could
be a challenge
and competition for business analyst
positions can be intense
so you should have a clear understanding
of the roles and responsibilities of a
business analyst
a ba should successfully identify and
recognize the organization's business
objective they should understand the
business problems and think of a
lucrative business solution
they need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders
allocate the right resources and improve
the existing business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst
bas interact with the development team
to design the solution for solving a
particular
problem they often need to spend a
certain amount of time in meetings in
order to save the development team from
spending their time and understanding
the stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application
as to what all features need to be added
and what functionalities should the
application contain
and also implement the newly designed
features that a business needs
while bas identify the needs define the
features right use cases
uncover business rules and manage issues
they should also gauge the functional
and non-functional requirements in a
business
business analysts run meeting with
stakeholders and other authorities
hence discussing issues with the client
face-to-face can do wonders
and even help in solving problems
quickly they engage with business
leaders and users to understand how
data-driven changes to products
services software and hardware can
improve efficiency
and add value they verify and validate
if the project is running well with the
help of user acceptance testing
and the solutions are in line with the
client's requirements
they also ensure that the product
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally bas write documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights
they also deliver maintenance reports
they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a project
business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills
often referred to as soft skills the
skills for a business analyst are not
only acquired through training but
through experience and combined with the
ability to understand situations
and the motive behind the problem so
let's have a look at the top skills to
become a successful business analyst
first and foremost you need to have a
degree in the related field
you can apply for entry level business
analyst positions right out of college
after earning a bachelor's degree in
business
accounting information systems human
resources
or another related field bas should have
outstanding analytical skills so that a
customer's business needs are properly
interpreted
and translated into application and
operational requirements
it is important for a ba to find ways to
quickly resolve problems
bas should find multiple ways to address
each challenge
they should be able to demonstrate that
they have identified various options
and explored the most viable ones hence
thinking logically will ensure
a project's successful completion
microsoft excel is one of the most
widely used powerful analytics
and reporting tools by bas for working
with tabular data
base create different charts and graphs
to generate dynamic reports related to a
problem
they create revenue growth models
calculate customer discounts based
on products purchased create weekly
plans and checklists
bas also manipulate data using different
functions
and find trends in the data
a business analyst is an intermediary
between variety of
people with various types of
personalities such as
developers clients and senior management
having the ability to balance those
individual expectations with what the
business actually needs
requires professional persuasion and
negotiation
you should be able to achieve a
profitable outcome for your company
while finding a solution for the client
that makes them happy
good knowledge of sql and relational
databases is
required for bas to access retrieve
manipulate and analyze data
bas often work with data that is
structured and is stored in the form of
rows and columns
so they should have a working knowledge
of microsoft sql server
oracle db mysql database and sqlite
bas need to write complex queries sql
scripts and stored procedures to
understand the data better
knowledge of programming languages such
as r and python is a prerequisite
business analysts should have a good
hands-on programming experience for
solving complex problems
and performing faster analysis of data
using these programming languages you
can analyze and visualize
large data sets and create predictive
models for making business decisions
python and r have a rich set of
libraries for data wrangling data
visualization and data modeling
some of them are numpy pandas d playart
idr
cyclone and carrit data visualization is
another key skill a business analyst
should possess
bas should be proficient in using
various business intelligence tools for
creating reports and dashboards
they build several types of reports such
as crosstab report column report query
report data entry report etc
hence knowledge of tableau click view
and power bi is needed for creating
visualizations forecasting data
and making decisions business analysts
spend a significant amount of time
interacting with clients
stakeholders developers as well as end
users
therefore being an effective
communicator is key business analysts
use
verbal and written communication to
convey ideas
concepts facts and opinions to a variety
of stakeholders
they should also be good at presentation
skills for conveying the results and
findings of a problem
now here is a quick roadmap that depicts
what a fresher needs to possess to
become a business analyst
first they need to have a graduation
degree in a related field
then knowledge of sql and relational
database
is very important thirdly a fresher
should have good hands-on experience
with programming languages and that's a
prerequisite
and finally they need to have good
communication skills to nail the role of
a business analyst
up next we have the roadmap that depicts
what an experienced professional needs
to possess to become a business analyst
firstly they should have good knowledge
of the domain they are currently working
in
next they should know how to write sql
queries
an experienced professional should be
good with programming languages
in addition to that they need to have
good communication and negotiation
skills
finally they should be good at creating
interactive reports using business
intelligence tools
in addition to that having a
certification offered by international
institute of business analysis
such as certified business analysis
professional would be highly beneficial
with that let's jump into understanding
the salary structure of a business
analyst
across different countries
according to pay scale the average
salary of a ba in the united states is
around sixty eight thousand nine hundred
and ninety dollars
again according to pay skill in india a
ba can earn nearly six lakh rupees per
annum
a ba can expect an average salary of
thirty five thousand six ninety pounds
in the united kingdom
according to pay scale and finally again
according to pay scale in australia a ba
can earn around eighty one thousand
seven seventy four australian dollars
finally let's have a look at some of the
companies hiring for bas
first we have the networking giant cisco
then we have the american financial
corporations capital one
and american express next we have the
social media messaging app
whatsapp search engine giant google and
services
network company ernest and young global
limited finally in our list of companies
we have the e-commerce leader amazon
and dell that brings us to the end of
this video on how to become a business
analyst
we hope you have found this informative
and helpful
if you enjoyed this video please like
and share it and don't forget to
subscribe to the simply learn channel
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here